bully is a documentary I had a chance to
see last night its documentary about how
boys can affect children and families in
America the documentary that tries to
personally put you in the lives of these
kids and the parents who are dealing
with bullying it's basically trying to
raise awareness for bullying and the
fact that bullying needs to stop and
there needs to be consequences for
bullying and it's documentary that can
be very educational for not only kids
but parents but especially school
authorities now I've seen a lot of
reviews for bully and I've noticed the
people's opinions tend to hinge on two
things number one if you tend to be more
of a politically minded person you might
look at this film and see a whole
political agenda that someone who's a
little bit more neutral or uninvolved
might not even see number two if you've
ever experienced bullying before in your
life or if you have it I think these two
things are really going to alter your
opinion of this film because I stayed
afterwards there was a huge question and
answer and it seemed like a lot of
people who were involved more in
politics and thought more about issues
and projects and you know giving money
to organizations and that kind of stuff
it seemed like they were a little bit
more questioning of the film I think
that the people who had experienced
bullying before in the audience seem to
connect with it more because it was more
of a personal film it was more something
that they were able to relate to cuz
they've experienced it before and I'll
just be honest with you when I was in
school I did get bullied a lot I was not
cool in middle school was just in middle
school really elementary school in high
school were fine in middle school though
that's those weird changing years it's
where all the kids are going through
puberty they don't understand what's
going on with their bodies they don't
understand what's going on around them
they're confused and so I got a lot of
bullying because I was a nerd I still am
a nerd but back then it wasn't really in
to be a nerd like now nowadays you see
people wear shirts that say geek is a
new sexy and you know everyone's into
various TV shows and they wear t-shirts
about it from Hot Topic and stuff and
geek is now kind of in when I was in
school not so much I was huge on Dragon
Ball Z Star Wars you know all that stuff
movies games I was a big nerd now I'm
six foot four I was always tall I was
always taller than everyone else so I
never got physically picked on no one
ever had the balls to pick a fight with
me it was just in like six and seventh
grade that I went through a lot of
bullying so I was able to connect a lot
with the people in this movie and for
that reason I think it's a very
effective documentary if you rate this
movie based off of connecting with its
audience and hopefully reaching the goal
that sets out to make
I think it's an effective documentary I
think of this documentary has shown at
schools if it's shown at principals and
people in authority people who can make
new rules at schools people who can
enforce this type of thing see it then I
think that it will cause some waves and
it will do well it's also something that
parents should be really aware of they
shouldn't be blinded to what's going on
in their kids lives at school the thing
is you know kids are only going to tell
their parents so many things when you're
in school you're not going to want to
tell your parents all the humiliating
things that happen to you more than
likely I have a way of seeing my
demographics on YouTube I can see the
ages and the genders that watch my
videos I know that the majority of the
people who watch my videos are between
the ages of 13 and 17 so I just want to
say if any of you guys are receiving
bullying in school if any of you guys
are dealing with that some people who
are just rude to you on the internet on
school wherever it is I feel for you I
understand how that is and I will tell
you that it will go away it will go away
it's going to end eventually one day and
all the things that bully made me think
about but the fact of the film had that
and got my mind turning the wheels in my
head going I have to commend it for that
I have a few problems with the
documentary and mainly their technical
issues because I look at things from a
directorial standpoint quite often I
really got annoyed with how often the
camera went in and out of focus
throughout this movie it happens so many
times I know they're filming live events
and that's very difficult to get the
focus right but I mean the entire movie
just goes like in and out of focus over
and over again that's just a technical
issue though bully is a good documentary
I think it's effective at what it's
trying to do I'm not looking at it from
a very political agenda or what's really
behind this thing or what are they
really trying to do I viewed it as a
film that's trying to express what
children and their families are going
through when they deal with this type of
thing and for that reason I think it's
very effective I'm going to give bully a
B do you guys have a favorite
documentary I know some of mine are like
march of the Penguins or supersize me
those are some really good documentaries
what are your guys favorites and as
always if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes